traiter ces patients sous hypnose sans
anesthésiant c'est ce que fait le
docteur mario beaulieu depuis une
trentaine d'années c'est rapide
sécuritaire un dollar une fois que la
relation de confiance est établie entre
un patient et j'ai plein filtrer les
reliefs plus jeunes que les rouges
durant l'intervention certains patients
voient peindre la différence c'est la
douleur qui est enlevée passer ceux qui
font rêver mais le reste les sensations
glisse en plus tu veux te détends toi ça
te sentir à redire et pop va devenir un
pilote alors je vais compter jusqu'à st
on sait depuis longtemps qu'en modifiant
l'état de conscience d'un patient on
peut diminuer ou éliminer sa douleur
mais les professionnels québécois qui
ont recours sont encore l'exception
c'est à d'ailleurs le sujet du récent
congrès international d'hypnose où il
était question des applications
médicales et kinect notamment salle
d'opération où par exemple on réalise
maintenant des chirurgies importantes
sur des patients sous hypnose qui n'ont
reçu qu'une anesthésie locale
l'avantagé de cette technique le patient
il reste conscient et l'anesthésié
générale c'est tacoma pharmacologique
réversible de préférence donc quand on
peut éviter le barça c'est toujours
mieux en europe
on utilise d'ailleurs pour plusieurs
indications médicales on sait ce qu'on
fait comment le fait là on fait les
zones où on agit
c'est ainsi qu'on peut agir sur les
enfants qui sont en troubles de
l'attention ce qui a trait fréquemment
ou d'hyperactivité ou des troubles du
sommeil des troubles du comportement
alimentaire l'été pression et c'est bien
en amérique l'hypnose piétinent alors
que les preuves de son efficacité
s'accumulent sauce une région du cortex
cérébral qui est associé aux émotions au
contrôle cognitif est révélée tu dis
depuis 15 ans les réactions à la douleur
d'un cerveau sous hypnose
ces travaux vont tous dans le même sens
en laboratoire ça fonctionne les
patients nous rapporte qu'elle sent
moins de douleur mellano imagerie nous
permet de voir qu effectivement un
changement dans la réponse des
structures du cérou qui sont impliqués
dans la douleur ce changement le
corrobore le rapport subjectif débat si
ça fonctionne également un cabinet
maintenant les données scientifiques au
moins dans le contrôle de la douleur de
l'anxiété sont très très solide
on voit aussi des études cliniques qui
sont très rigoureuses dont je pense que
la transition est en train de se faire
vers une application plus généralisé
dans les milieux cliniques également la
beauté de la chose c'est que non
seulement ces coups ç'a pas d'effets
secondaires non plus ça dure longtemps
la pédiatre sylvie lafrenière qui
utilisent cette technique fréquemment
crois que la dimension parfois
spectaculaires de l'hypnose nui à son
image auprès des professionnels de la
santé
il faut arrêter de voir l'hypnose comme
la grosse et ans chez le psychologue
avec le pendule c'est quelquefois
quelques minutes
une suggestion bien placé un enfant qui
est un peu mal tu russell calme un petit
fait juste une suggestion et voilà c'est
parti
un avis que partage cette spécialiste
des soins palliatifs c'est une culture
puis ça prend du temps faire changer les
mentalités du sommet je sens plus de
résistance auprès de la communauté
médicale que du grand public ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal